israel is building up forces for a
potential invasion of gaza escalating
the region's worst crisis in years
the israeli military bombarded targets
inside gaza overnight while palestinian
militants fired more rockets from the
territory
this week's attacks have killed at least
eight israelis and more than 100
palestinians
mts is near the border with gaza where
israeli troops
are amassing good morning
good morning well we're very close to
the barrier with gaza and you can see
israeli tanks sort of stretching all the
way down that way we have israeli
soldiers there
as well and this really follows what is
perhaps the most
intense night of fighting inside the
gaza strip with
israeli forces carrying out air strike
after airstrike
and indeed ground forces firing
munitions
into the gaza strip and what people in
gaza are saying something
they have never seen in all the years of
fighting
[Applause]
it's the heaviest bombardment of gaza
yet
overnight israeli airstrikes pummeled
the densely populated palestinian
territory
while on the ground israeli soldiers
fired artillery shells from their
positions
along the separation wall smashing hamas
tunnel networks
thousands of palestinians fled the
assault carrying whatever they could
with parents clinging on to their
children
this woman says the kids are all afraid
even us
adults who have been in war since our
childhood are afraid
we cannot bear this anymore israel's
relentless campaign was clouded with
confusion after a military spokesperson
told the international media on thursday
that its soldiers were quote on the
ground in gaza
then later saying they weren't an
apparent miscommunication
the israeli media says could have been
part of a deliberate ploy to confuse
hamas but it didn't slow hamas's
campaign of rocket fire
eighteen hundred have been fired at
israel since the conflict began
in the israeli town of sardot where a
five-year-old child was killed
in rocket fire on wednesday residents
were calling for blood
it's very very difficult to live under
this uh
circumstances and the government should
wipe out gaza
should wipe out gaza once and for all
israel is facing multiple fronts as
violence continues to rage in the
country's mixed
jewish and arab towns in the worst
communal fighting
seen for decades prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
has refused the ceasefire agreement with
hamas
and is vowing to crush the unrest in
israel with a quote iron fist
which many are worrying could lead to
more bloodshed
thank you mta's taya reporting from
israel